i know i'm really blessed
i don't know what it is like
i couldn't tell you like if it's like
man [ __ ] just start working and like
people be like i got a lot of hard work
ethic and stuff like that
right and then i look back and see it
and i like i enjoy working hard and
stuff like that
but you get lost when you're doing
something that you want to do
like you tell me like i love doing this
[ __ ] so it don't feel like i'm working
hard
right it doesn't feel like that to me
like you feel me so when people be like
oh like he's so humble and he like he
felt me he worked so hard he put in so
much work like
like this what you're supposed to do
yeah yeah i mean you live if you love
what you're doing they say you never
work a day in your life yeah i ain't
working this [ __ ] is just
you feel me it's work but i ain't
working right you know
it's work because other people are
involved now so now i got to like you
feel me it becomes work when it's like
other people's livelihood or is that all
right [ __ ] like
you feeling me like this is how they
make they money that's how they feed
their family and stuff like that so you
got to do your part
so that to make sure everybody feel me
because they're taking a chance on you
you feel me so when it becomes that
that's when i start understanding like
it's work
but making music is not work for me you
know like that [ __ ] just fun like i like
to make music you know
and i'm always going through [ __ ] like
y'all you always are inspired to d
yeah you like you say if you're always
going through [ __ ] or you're living your
life you're going to have
new content to write every day that's
some real [ __ ] people don't be living
or people be faking what they be living
that's real bro people don't be living
like that
they'd be on their phone at home or
they'd be yeah but [ __ ] go on a song
and talk about you killed six [ __ ]
today like
you ain't no you didn't you've been
playing 2k all day like
right right around me i'm gonna talk
about 2k
[ __ ] always want to use lebron nigga's
not good
hey man shout out to my son that's my
son man my son always should be picking
the lakers i'm like bro come on man
like pick somebody up three randoms man
three randoms come on yeah i always tell
them i'm like yo just hit the r2 let the
randoms pick and we'll see who wins
yeah or let's pick the two worst teams
in the league and then let's see
who plays then let's see who [ __ ]
wins yes let's see who's good with the
pistons the homies always use the lakers
and the bucks
man yeah giannis is a cheat code in the
game too man